our cities today have multiple severe
issues which are only getting worse and
most of them are caused by urban
motorization the five main issues we can
identify are as follows number one noise
pollution and the youtube user not just
bikes already did a great coverage of
this in his video entitled cities aren't
loud cars are loud through motorization
we lost our right to peace and quiet
those are now behind a paywall namely
areas that are quiet and have good
connections to the center and are
consequently ultra expensive problem
number two is of course air pollution
now aside from the early deaths and the
respiratory problems air pollution can
literally lower your iq if you grow up
in a polluted area and have you develop
all kinds of psychological problems
later on problem number three is simply
lack of space our streets used to be
massive social spaces now we use them as
transit arteries and parking lots damn
it almost sounds like this was some kind
of business scheme from the cod industry
so they can sell us more cars problem
number four is safety since our streets
were given over to cars they are no
longer safe to be on inside cities you
cannot let your children go play on the
street since they would get run over
similarly all pets have to stay indoors
for the same reason and so problem
number 5 is overheating 2021 was already
the hottest summer ever in some places
and this trend will only get worse now
of course we have had massive heat waves
even in the past but the problem is that
in the meantime we turned our cities
into black cauldrons of asphalt with
metal boxes in it and this makes cities
practically uninhabitable during a major
heat wave so these are the five most
immediate problems we face and the
solution one word superblocks
superblocks are the closest thing we get
to a silver bullet type solution they
can solve all the aforementioned
problems by design so what exactly are
superblocks in short they are
human-friendly areas of the city where
all public space belongs to pedestrians
and cyclists and where cars are treated
as guests barcelona has been a
trailblazer in this regard it's
superblocks being a massive success no
pun intended as of now vienna is also
preparing its first superblock so good
for them so how do you make a superblock
it's very easy actually and cheap step 1
find an area delineated by major roads
this will be the initial area of the
superblock ideally it should have mixed
zoning and existing public transit links
which connected to other parts of the
city a metro or train station are the
best in this regard but trams and buses
can also do the job step 2 reorganize
directions of traffic in practice this
means strategically placed one-way
streets arrange them in a way that it is
possible to drive in and out of the area
but not through it eliminating transit
traffic is the key to the superblock
design bicycles and street-level public
transit should be exempt from this of
course and at this point most of the
work is already done isn't that great
and all it took was putting up some
one-way street signs that being said
these measures must be followed up by
others namely step 3 limit parking for
non-residents without this step your
superblock will just become an inner
city parking lot only residents should
be able to park their cars inside and
the pricing should disincentivize car
ownership let alone having multiple cars
pricing should also take into account
size and propulsion a person owning a
ford f-350 should pay much more than
someone within his sun leave step 4 turn
streets into mixed traffic spaces once
there are no clearly delineated traffic
lanes and there are people all around
drivers will automatically be more
careful no really this solves both the
lack of space and the safety issues due
to our previous measures there are much
fewer cars than before meaning a ton of
former road and parking space is freed
up and the streets can now be shared by
all we now have space for bike lanes
restaurant terraces and very importantly
rows of trees to keep things cool during
the summer step 5. no that was it
congratulations you just made an entire
district much more livable for everyone
but mainly for the silent majority the
non-drivers and all it took was two main
steps and two follow-up ones the noise
and air pollution are now gone we freed
up a ton of space there is no threat of
getting run over and the street no
longer turns into a frying pan during
summer this is how we take our streets
back from cars and make cities livable
once more this is the future of urban
planning it's easy to organize and
rather cheap to implement all you need
is a political leadership not made up of
car centric boomers oh wait at this
point you might be thinking okay
superblocks are nice but how do i get
one in my city you know i'm not from
vienna or barcelona to which i say don't
worry there is a way even if you live in
places like phoenix or miami and so you
have two main options really number one
is to vote for a political party which
is pro-d congestion and they have a
chance of getting into the local
legislature number two is to join a
local advocacy group for public
transportation decongestion that sort of
thing attend meetings and events get to
know people network organize now chances
are you're not going to be advocating
for super blocks right off the bat
especially if you live in america
depending on how far gone your city is
you'll have to be getting different
places so for example someone living in
a traditional european city core might
just go ahead and advocate for
superplugs right off the bat while
someone living in phoenix or miami or
other refronts to god might need to
begin somewhere else for example
abolishing parking minimums would be a
good start or if that's not an option
just try to reduce them any step in the
right direction is by definition a good
step so there you go i guess super
blocks and the way to achieve them thank
you for watching and don't forget to
like and subscribe and i'll be seeing
you next time
you